I think it's going to be less painful
than you think that's gonna mean I'm
interested to see the amount of pain I
think it's necessary for guys to realize
what we go through for grooming purposes
I'm on the couch like do anything being
a working woman and he comes over and he
looks at my hairy legs I'm looking
forward to wipe my ass and there not
being any resistance I like it when
Becky slacks and that's like me to know
what it feels like
kori I mean advice to make sure that
everything goes well with the waxing I
will be doing all the prep applying the
wax and I will teach the girls how to
remove the wax safely for their
boyfriends and if you wanted revenge
this is the perfect time putting a
zipper up that's exactly how you're
gonna do like you but my testicles yeah
arrest me or in the way one two three
[Music]
[Music]
I mean look here let's do this you know
the Exorcist will my pubic hair is
apparently a demon and my body is
revolting to it in every way shape and
form
[Music]
you're blaming slightly hey I'm like she
got a nice little [ __ ]
I'm Victoria because I want her to feel
like she's doing a good job but also
like a son comfort I'm torn chookies
when with you I'm like oh my god then
with her like yeah this is gonna be
worse than meeting your parents
oh I appreciate the trust you have trust
babe
as we're like looking at your paper I
know this is easily one of the if not
the most painful thing oh god no mad
respect women mad respect
but hell no how do you feel
I've looked at myself in the mirror snot
on my dick look like a naked mole if I
had to wax and have periods in Alaska I
know I'm sorry so mad love tell you
ladies see this might be a once in a
lifetime experience for me but to anyone
who does this Bravo because this is
insane
[Music]